GREG.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST WRAPPING UP
A MEETING WITH FBI DIRECTOR
CHRIS WRAY, DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN,
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE DAN COATS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THIS COMES AS THE PRESIDENT IS
DEMANDING ANSWERS OVER A SERIES
OF REPORTS THAT AN FBI INFORMANT
WAS IN CONTACT WITH ASSOCIATES
OF HIS CAMPAIGN.
TRUMPET TWEETING THAT THE DOJ
NEEDS TO INVESTIGATE IF THE
CAMPAIGN WAS "INFILTRATED OR
SURVEILLED AND IF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WAS INVOLVED."
DOJ IS RESPONDING BY ASKING ITS
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO LOOK AT
THESE ALLEGATIONS.
VICE PRESIDENT-ELECT PENCE IS
REACTING TO THE LATEST
DEVELOPMENT IN A SIT DOWN WITH
MARTHA MacCALLUM.
>> THE PRESIDENT I THINK HE IS
GRATEFUL THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS GOING TO HAVE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL LOOK INTO IT
AND DETERMINE AND ENSURE THAT
THERE WAS NO SURVEILLANCE DONE
FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES.
AGAINST OUR CAMPAIGN.
I THINK IT WOULD BE VERY
TROUBLING TO MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS OF THAT TOOK PLACE.
>> Jesse: HOUSE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES IS SAYING
IF THIS IS TRUE, IT'S A MAJOR
SCANDAL.
>> IF THEY RAN A SPY RING OR
INFORMANT RING AND THEY WERE
PAYING PEOPLE WITHIN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, IF ANY OF THAT IS
TRUE, THAT IS AN ABSOLUTE
REDLINE.
YOU CAN DO THIS TO POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS.
ACCORDING TO THEM, THIS WAS DONE
IN THE SPRING BEFORE THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION WAS EVEN OPENED.
IF THAT'S TRUE, WE NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT IT.
>> Jesse: MEANWHILE FORMER DOJ
OFFICIAL SALLY YATES IS LOSING
IT OVER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
REQUEST.
>> WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS THE
PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN HIS ALL-OUT
ASSAULT ON THE RULE OF LAW TO A
NEW LEVEL.
THIS TIME HE IS ORDERING UP AN
INVESTIGATION OF THE
INVESTIGATORS.
WHO ARE EXAMINING HIS OWN
CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S REALLY SHOCKING.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, YOU WOULD
EXPECT PEOPLE FROM THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION TO SAY THINGS
LIKE THAT, FORMER CIA DIRECTOR
JOHN BRENNAN ALSO LASHED OUT ON
TWITTER.
BUT IF THIS INFORMATION IS
CORRECT, KIMBERLY, HOW
DEVASTATING WOULD IT BE FOR OUR
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES?
>> Kimberly: IT IS QUITE
DISCONCERTING WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT.
IF THERE'S ACTUALLY AN ACTIVE
SPY OPERATION WITHIN A CAMPAIGN,
YOU WOULD HOPE THAT IF THEY
THOUGHT THERE WAS A VEIN THAT
WAS AT RISK WITH RESPECT TO
RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE, THAT THEY
WOULD IN FACT GO TO CANDIDATE
TRUMP AT THE TIME OR SOME
OFFICIAL IN THE CAMPAIGN AND SAY
LISTEN WE HAVE SOME
INFORMATION WE BELIEVE PERHAPS
YOUR CAMPAIGN COULD HAVE AN
ISSUE AND SOMEONE COULD TRY TO
GET INVOLVED OR TRIED TO GET
INTELLIGENCE FROM YOU.
BUT THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
IT'S SORT OF BELIES THAT TRUTH
AND ACCURACY OF IT, AND THEN YOU
SAW "THE NEW YORK TIMES" PREEMPT
AND PUT THIS OUT THERE IN
ADVANCE OF THE IG REPORT WHICH
IS EXPECTED TO BE DAMNING.
THEY SAY WE ARE LOOKING TO
PROTECT YOU.
IT DOESN'T RING TRUE.
WHY WOULDN'T YOU BE TRANSPARENT
AND TELL THEM INSTEAD OF TRYING
TO ENTRAP?
THE FBI'S JOB IS NOT TO SPY ON
CAMPAIGNS OR PLAY SOMEBODY
WITHIN AN ORGANIZATION LIKE THAT
WITHIN AN ORGANIZATION LIKE THA
THAT.
COMPLETELY OUT-OF-BOUNDS.
>> Jesse: COMEY SAID HE WAS
SUSPICIOUS IN THE SPRING OF
2016, DECIDED NOT TO INFORM THE
CAMPAIGN IN THE SPRING THAT THE
RUSSIANS MIGHT BE UP TO
SOMETHING.
AND THEN THEY LOOKED AT
PAPADOPOULOS I THINK IN JULY OR
AUGUST, GREG, THEY DIDN'T EVEN
INTERVIEW HIM UNTIL JANUARY.
THEY WAITED SIX MONTHS.
WHY NOT, IF PAPADOPOULOS HAD
HEARD SOMETHING, WHY NOT ASK
THEM STRAIGHT UP WHAT IS GOING
ON?
>> Greg: THE MORE THEY KEEP
TRYING TO FIND COLLUSION, THE
MORE THEY FIND DEMOCRATS.
THIS SCANDAL OR PSEUDO-SCANDAL
IS ACTUALLY EASIER TO EXPLAIN TO
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC THAT ALL OF
THE OTHER COLLUSION STUFF.
THEY SENT AN INFORMANT INTO TRAP
TRUMP.
I LOVE THE MEDIA EXPLANATION FOR
THIS.
WE ONLY SENT THIS INFORMANT IN
THERE TO PROTECT DONALD TRUMP.
WE WERE SPYING ON YOU AS A
FAVOR.
THAT IS LIKE SAYING THAT I AM
STALKING YOU AS A FAVOR.
ICE TOOL YOUR CAR SO NO ONE ELSE
WOULD STEAL YOUR CAR.
IT'S THE PLOT OF "NATIONAL
TREASURE" WHEN NICOLAS CAGE
STEALS THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE.
WHY DID THIS HAPPEN?
WHY DID JOHN BRENNAN, WHY DID
THEY DO THIS SET UP, WHY DID
THEY SET THE TRAP?
I BELIEVE THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE
DOING GOD'S WORK.
THAT THEY WERE ENERGIZED BY THE
FRANTIC ALARMIST MEDIA ABOUT
TRUMP OF WHICH I INCLUDE MYSELF
BECAUSE I WAS EVERY BIT AS
WORRIED ABOUT TRUMP AS ANYBODY
DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
I HAVE TO SAY I AM PART OF THE
ALARMIST MEDIA.
I THINK IF YOU WATCH THE NEWS
AND YOU ARE PART OF THE NEWS AND
YOU ARE PART OF THE GOVERNMENT,
YOU CONVINCE YOURSELF THAT IF
TRUMP BECAME PRESIDENT, THE
COUNTRY WOULD BE IN PERIL.
THEREFORE DOING SOMETHING LIKE
THIS, WHICH IS ILLEGAL, IS
ACTUALLY PATRIOTIC.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT PETER
STRZOK HIMSELF TEXTED.
>> Greg: BUT THEY ARE WRONG.
I ADMIT I WAS WRONG.
THEY HAVE TO ADMIT THEY ARE
WRONG.
THEY MIGHT HAVE TO GO TO JAIL.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE MAKING MORE
MONEY THAN USUAL.
THANK YOU, DONALD TRUMP.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
>> Jesse: NOW THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS ASKED THE DOJ TO
DO THIS, FLIPPING THE SCRIPT,
WHAT WILL IT DO TO THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
DOES IT ELONGATED?
>> Dana: I SAW CHRIS CHRISTIE
DOING AN INTERVIEW TODAY WHERE
HE SAID THAT HE HAS GIVEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP A LOT OF ADVICE
AND HE SAID HE TELLS THEM THERE
ARE WAYS TO SHORTEN THIS
INVESTIGATION AND WAYS TO MAKE
IT LONGER.
SO FAR, PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
TAKEN EVERY STEP TO MAKE IT
LONGER.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW IF WITH      WHEN
RUDY GIULIANI SAID MUELLER TOLD
ME IT WOULD BE WRAPPED UP BY
DECEMBER 1ST.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF I WOULD SAY
THAT.
I'M WILLING TO BELIEVE THE OBAMA
TEAM HAD DONE THIS.
THEY WERE POLITICALLY MOTIVATED.
BUT ALL OF THESE THINGS, IF IT'S
TRUE, IF IT'S TRUE, IF IT'S TRUE
REMINDS ME OF THEY WIRETAPPED ME
UP TRUMP TOWER WHICH TURNS OUT
NOT TO HAVE BEEN THE CASE.
I GUESS WE DON'T KNOW, AND THUS
MAY BE IN THE WHOLE
INVESTIGATION WE FOUND OUT THAT
SOMEBODY ON THE CAMPAIGN DID
HAVE A WIRETAP.
A >> Jesse: I THINK MANAFORT
HAD AN APARTMENT AT TRUMP TOWER.
>> Dana: MAYBE THEY SHOULDN'T
OF HIRED MANAFORT.
I AM WILLING TO WAIT FOR THE
EVIDENCE AND I THINK OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL HOWEVER ONE
SEEMS TO ADMIRE AT LEAST SO FAR
UNTIL HE SAYS SOMETHING THEY
DON'T LIE, THAT EVERYONE THINKS
HE'S DOING A PRETTY GOOD JOB,
THEY'RE WAITING FOR THE REPORT
ON SECRETARY CLINTON'S EMAIL.
I THINK THE HILLARY CLINTON TEAM
HAS A RIGHT TO BE SOMEWHAT MAD,
THAT THEIR POSITION IS YOU MEAN
TO TELL ME THAT THE FBI WAS
WILLING TO GO OUT ON THE RECORD
WITH THE DIRECTOR TO SAY THAT I
WOULD -- I WAS BEING
INVESTIGATED, HILLARY CLINTON,
AND THEN THEY PLAYED DOWN
"NEW YORK TIMES" INQUIRIES ABOUT
THE TRUMP TEAM BEING UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK THEY
THOUGHT TRUMP WAS GOING TO WIN.
>> Dana: THE FBI OR HILLARY?
>> Greg: I THINK HILLARY
SHOULD BE UPSET THAT THE
GOVERNMENT DIDN'T SEND A SPY
INTO HER CAMPAIGN TO PROTECT
THAT IS SEXISM.
>> Dana: TO SAY YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO WIN MICHIGAN.
>> Kimberly: PROTECT HER FROM
HERSELF.
>> Jesse: ACCORDING TO THE
MEDIA, IT WAS NOT A SPY.
IT WAS JUST AN INFORMANT.
>> Juan: BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID "EMBEDDED."
THERE WAS NO ONE EMBEDDED IN THE
CAMPAIGN.
THIS GUY IS A PROFESSOR
SOMEWHERE IN BRITAIN AND WHAT HE
DID WAS HE CAME INTO CONTACT
WITH THREE OH OFFICIALS, THREE
OF WHOM HAD ALREADY PREVIOUSLY
BEEN IMPLICATED IN TERMS OF
CONNECTIONS TO RUSSIA.
>> Jesse: WE HEARD IT WAS
FOUR.
>> Juan: OKAY.
I WILL GO THREE.
CARTER PAGE, GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS
CARTER PAGE, GEORGE PAPADOPOULO
PAPADOPOULOS, AND WHO'S THE
OTHER?
>> Jesse: FLYNN AND MANAFORT.
>> Juan: NO, THERE WAS ANOTHER
ONE.
>> Jesse: EITHER WAY, YOU TALK
TO THE CAMPAIGN PEOPLE.
>> Juan: THE POINT IS NOBODY
WAS EMBEDDED AND WHAT YOU HAVE
IS A LEGITIMATE INVESTIGATION OF
THE IDEA THAT RUSSIA IS
INTERFERING IN AN AMERICAN
ELECTION AND THEY DON'T LAUNCH,
BY THE WAY, A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
THEY DO A COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
ALL THEY ARE DOING IS TRYING TO
FIND OUT WHAT'S GOING ON.
THE THING THAT CONCERNS ME, AND
I PICKED UP ON THIS, I THINK
IT'S WHAT SALLY YATES WAS
TALKING ABOUT.
WE RELY ON OUR INTELLIGENCE
PEOPLE, AND IF YOU START
DOUBTING THEM, THIS COMES FROM
CHRISTOPHER WRAY, YOU DO THAT,
YOU PUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU
PUT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC AT GREAT
RISK IF WE CAN'T PROTECT OUR
AGENTS.
>> Greg: THEY MADE IT PRETTY
CLEAR WHO HE WAS IN A NUMBER OF
WAYS.
IF THEY REALLY DID CARE, AND
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN FAIR ABOUT
THIS AND THEY WOULD HAVE DEALT
WITH BOTH CAMPAIGNS.
THEY ARE SAYING NOW OH, THE
RUSSIANS WERE MORE INTERESTED IN
TRUMP.
THAT'S CONVENIENT NOW THAT
EVERYBODY FINDS OUT YOU'VE BEEN
PUTTING INFORMANTS.
>> Juan: EVERYBODY HAS SAID,
EVERYBODY FROM THE BIPARTISAN
SENATE COMMITTEE HAS SAID RUSSIA
FAVORED DONALD TRUMP TO WIN.
WE LEARNED THIS WEEKEND, THE
SAUDIS, THE ISRAELIS HAVE ALSO
SAID WE HAVE AN INTEREST IN
HELPING YOU OUT, MR. TRUMP.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO KNOW WHAT
THE CHINESE DID WITH HILLARY.
>> Greg: JUAN, LET ME ASK YOU
A QUESTION.
>> Juan: OBAMA, CLINTON.
>> Greg: THEY PAY THE GUY
$400,000.
>> Jesse: THE WEEK AFTER THE
DNC SERVER WAS ALLEGEDLY HACKED
BY THE RUSSIANS, THEY OPEN UP A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION TO SEE ABOUT
RUSSIAN HACKING.
KIMBERLY, THEY NEVER SEIZED THE
SERVER.
THEY NEVER LOOKED AT THE SERVER,
RAN AN INVESTIGATION ON THE
SERVER, DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
-- WOULDN'T YOU THINK THAT WOULD
BE THE FIRST THING THEY WOULD
DO?
>> Kimberly: YOU WOULD THINK.
HOW ABOUT TURN OVER THE
PHYSICAL, TANGIBLE EVIDENCE SO
THEY CAN DO A PROPER FORENSICS
EXAMINATION AND SEE IF THEY CAN
RETRIEVE ANY DELETED FILES.
IT SHOWS THE HYPOCRISY AND HOW
THE DISINGENUOUS.
WHEN THEY HAVE EVIDENCE OF
ACTUAL MALFEASANCE AND THINGS
GOING ON, THEY DON'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
BUT THEN THEY TRIED TO CONJURE
UP LIKE EVIL SPIRITS AN IDEA OF
COLLUSION AND THEN SAY JUST
LOOKING OUT FOR YOU, BUDDY.
THEY PUT SOME ON YOUR CAMPAIGN,
THEY ARE CHANGING THE STORY SAY
NO, WE ARE TRYING TO PROTECT
YOU.
BUT WAIT, AND INFORMANT BUT NOT
A SPY.
VERBAL GYMNASTICS.
>> Juan: NONE OF THIS CHANGES
ANYTHING.
>> Jesse: YOU DON'T THINK?
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK IT
CHANGES A BIT.
WE ARE STILL DEALING WITH THE
IDEA THAT RUSSIANS ARE TRYING TO
INTERFERE IN THE CAMPAIGN.
WE ARE WAITING TO FIND OUT WHAT
MUELLER HAS.
WHAT WE HAVE IS THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS AIDES THROWING IT UP AND
NOW --
>> Jesse: THIS WAS A LEAK FROM
PEOPLE IN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND
"WASHINGTON POST" TO GET OUT
AHEAD OF IT.
I WILL TELL YOU WHY THERE IS
SUSPICION, JUAN.
LET ME FINISH.
>> Juan: I HEREBY ORDER MY OWN
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT?
NOW THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS A
POLITICAL TOOL?
>> Jesse: AND IT WAS NOT
SUSPICIOUS -- UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, AP REPORTERS AND
FOX REPORTERS WERE LOOKED INTO.
CONGRESS WAS SURVEILLED.
ALL OF A SUDDEN AND OPPOSING
CAMPAIGN IS SURVEILLED AND
EVERYONE IS SAYING OH, YOU KNOW
WHAT.
>> Kimberly: NO PROBLEM.
>> Juan: WHAT WAS THAT ABOUT?
MUCH TO MY CHAGRIN BECAUSE I
DIDN'T LIKE IT.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THEY WERE
AFTER?
LEAKS.
LEAKS FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT TRUMP
COMPLAINS ABOUT, LEAKS.
THEY CRACKDOWN ON REPORTERS IN A
WAY THAT I DON'T THINK IS LEGIT
BUT THAT'S WHAT IT WAS ABOUT.
>> Jesse: EVERYTHING THEY LEFT
HAS SAID ABOUT THIS HAS BEEN